if Britain chooses to ring in a new era
the only thing that won't miss a beat is
Big Ben
but EU representatives fear the
consequences of losing a key member
state Chancellor Merkel is hustling
appealing to Brussels to meet British
Prime Minister David Cameron partway
with reforms so Britain will remain in
the European Union some experts say the
EU without the UK would be a worst case
scenario for Germany as a trading
partner and for balance within the EU
of course Great Britain is one of the EU
donor countries and there's a mounting
hostility on the part of Germany the
Netherlands and a few Scandinavian
countries since the rest of the EU
states are on the receiving end that
means Germany alone would be what's left
of the big countries that donate EU
funds if Britain leaves British
politicians like to joke that Cameron
sees the German Chancellor more often
than his own wife the British prime
minister and miracle have a lot in
common as they both favor EU reforms
greater economic competitiveness and
less bureaucracy and miracle is known
for managing to avoid confrontation in
the face of British concerns about the
appointment of jean-claude Juncker from
Belgium as new EU Commission chief I
feel it's grossly negligent unacceptable
really that some people say it doesn't
matter whether or not Britain agrees and
even whether or not Britain remains in
the EU the Chancellor helped smooth the
way forward during the decisive EU
summit in February
Cameron needed successes that he could
take home to use in the remain campaign
I do not love Brussels
I love Britain and my job the job of the
British prime minister is doing all in
my power to protect Britain's interests
Britain was able to opt out of greater
European integration for example it can
cut benefits for European immigrants the
talks were long
the Chancellor needed a night snack of
Belgian fries to keep up her strength
German politicians are hoping the leave
vote fails they're concerned the --use
political weight in the world would be
diminished without the UK take the Iran
nuclear deal as an example it's clear
that individual European countries
aren't being taken seriously but
together we can have an impact and I
think the EU without Britain would be
severely compromised
like the Chancellor the majority of
Germans weren't Britain to remain in the
EU they want the British prime minister
in Brussels to to debate Europe's future
brexit would mean a new era for both
Britain and the European Union
you